en el vídeo anterior hablamos sólo de la
primera energía de ionización en este
vídeo compararemos la primera y segunda
energía de ionización y utilizaremos al
litio como nuestro ejemplo en el vídeo
anterior vimos que el litio tiene un
número atómico de 3 tiene 3 protones en
el núcleo y en un átomo neutro de litio
el número de electrones es igual al
número de protones y entonces sabemos
que hay 3 electrones en el litio aquí la
configuración electrónica es
de 22
tenemos 2 electrones en el orbital 1 s
continuamos dibujando a los 2 electrones
en el orbital 1 s de esa manera y
tenemos un electrón más que irá en el
orbital 12 s de esa manera esta sería
una representación muy simple del átomo
neutro de litio si aplicamos suficiente
energía podríamos incluso quitar este
electrón podríamos quitarlo y llamamos a
esto la primera energía de ionización es
la primera energía de ionización y para
quitar ese electrón necesitamos
aproximadamente 520 kilos por mol
y ya que quitamos ese electrón sabemos
que ya no tenemos un átomo neutro de
litio ahora tenemos un ión de litio
porque aún tenemos tres cargas positivas
en el núcleo pero ahora tenemos sólo dos
cargas negativas ahora sólo tenemos dos
electrones porque le quitamos 13 menos 2
nos da más 1
este es el camión litio + 1 y la
configuración electrónica sería sólo 1s
2 porque perdimos el electrón en el
orbital 2 eso y entonces podemos
continuar podemos aplicar más energía y
quitar otro electrón digamos que
quitamos a este electrón esta vez
estamos quitando un segundo electrón y
no llamaríamos a esto energía de
ionización
la llamaremos energía de ionización 2
porque esto quitar a un segundo electrón
este valor resulta ser aproximadamente 7
mil 298 kilos jules por mol y si
quitamos ese segundo electrón
normalmente tenemos a tres cargas
positivas en el núcleo pero queda solo
una carga negativa ahora tenemos sólo un
electrón por lo que esto ya no es el
camión de litio más uno más bien será el
catch ión de litio más 2 porque 3 - 2 es
más dos esto de aquí es litio más 2 y la
configuración electrónica será sólo un
electrón en el orbital 1 s 1s 1
así que vemos que hay una gran
diferencia entre la primera energía de
ionización y la segunda energía de
ionización 520 contra 7.298 veamos si
podemos explicar la razón para esta
diferencia extremadamente grande en las
energías de ionización utilizaremos tres
factores que mencionamos en el vídeo
anterior el primer factor fue la
ya
luz
la cual se refiere al número de protones
en el núcleo si vemos el átomo neutro de
litio tres cargas positivas en el núcleo
las cargas positivas van a atraer a este
electrón magenta y si vemos el catión
con una carga de más 1 de litio pasa
algo similar aún tenemos 3 protones en
el núcleo esa carga positiva va a estar
atrayendo a este electrón también y
entonces ya tienen el mismo número de
protones
tenemos que pensar más que nada en la
carga nuclear efectiva en lugar de en
los protones en nuestro núcleo y antes
de hacer eso debemos de considerar el
efecto del apantallamiento de electrones
hablemos ver
ya
miel
de electrones ahora también es llamado
blind
da
de electrones apantallamiento blindaje
de electrones cuando pensamos en el
apantallamiento de electrones pensamos
en los electrones internos de aquí
regresando al átomo neutro del litio
estos dos electrones internos de aquí
van a repeler
este electrón en el último orbital
este repeler a a este también
así que puedes pensar que apantallan al
electrón en magenta de sentir la fuerza
de las tres cargas positivas del núcleo
porque los electrones repelen a los
otros electrones y entonces la manera de
calcular la carga nuclear efectiva he
hecho esto en vídeos anteriores también
la manera simple de calcular la carga
nuclear efectiva es tomar el número de
protones más 3 y a eso le restas el
número de electrones que brindan en este
caso serían estos 2 electrones en el
orbital 1 s + 3 menos 2 nos da una carga
nuclear efectiva de más 1
y entonces el electrón en magenta no
está sintiendo una carga nuclear de 3
sólo está sintiendo una carga nuclear
efectiva cercana a 1 porque el valor
real es de hecho aproximadamente
punto 3 cuando hacen los cálculos más
complicados lo que ocasiona el
apantallamiento de electrones es
disminuir la carga nuclear neta que este
electrón en magenta siente y entonces
cuando vemos este electrón este electrón
en magenta para el cateo nmás1 del litio
realmente no es la misma situación no
hay tanto apantallamiento de electrones
este electrón de aquí podría repeler un
poco pero no hay electrones en orbitales
internos que repelan a este electrón en
magenta y debido a eso el electrón en
magenta sentirá esta carga positiva de
más 3 mucho más sentirá casi toda la
carga positiva del núcleo y por eso
habrá una fuerza de atracción mucho
mayor
jalando a este electrón en magenta hacia
este núcleo y por ende tienes que
aplicar más energía para quitar ese
electrón
lo que te dice el efecto del
apantallamiento de electrones es que el
segundo electrón es mucho más difícil de
quitar que el primero así que vemos un
gran incremento en la energía de
ionización de la primera energía de
ionización a la segunda energía de
ionización y el último factor que
discutimos fue
gris
así que la distancia de esos electrones
en magenta desde el núcleo en la
izquierda regresando con el átomo neutro
del litio este electrón está en el
segundo nivel de energía está más
alejado que esté electrón este electrón
está en el primer nivel de energía 1 s 2
así que esta distancia de aquí es más
pequeña que la distancia en la izquierda
como la distancia es menor este electrón
en magenta siente más fuerza de
atracción del núcleo nuevamente eso dice
en la ley de coulón y por ende hay un
incremento a la fuerza de atracción por
eso requiere es más energía para quitar
a ese electrón se requiere mucha más
energía para quitar el segundo electrón
que el primero y es por eso que vemos un
incremento en la energía de ionización
la distancia dice que el hecho de que
esté
y esté más cerca hace que se requiera
más energía para quitarlo y esa es otra
razón por la cual este número que
representa la segunda energía de
ionización sea mucho más grande que el
primero necesitas mucha más energía para
quitar un segundo electrón y eso explica
por qué vemos al litio formando un
catión uno más se necesita menos energía
para quitar un electrón que para quitar
dos electrones y formar litio más dos
esta es una manera de decir qué tipo de
ión se formará de la energía de
ionización y cuando veas una diferencia
grande te dará una idea de cuáles iones
son más fáciles de formar